antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage
l'émission était de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
le vieux piano de la place le joueur
console quand solitude vieux pianos de
la place à des clients dont l'habitude
et de danse à samedi lé dimanche les
autres jours ça sur les planches dans la
mer qui se souvient il rêve sont faits
c'est alors le centre court battu de ma
cachette
et puis soudain de rang tremblante ému
en lui chemin inverse
mais c'était nous tout ce qu'un jour
tout comme cette musique jali mais
proulx me fait du mal
me fait du bien on n'en sait trop rien
adieu adieu piano
bonsoir bienvenue au bar de la plage
avec vont ils faire un enfant
la presse est sur les dents rendent
heures et décadence de la petite fille
de mamy blue madame thérèse fait dépit à
cogolin la plage à la page
andré bercoff ivres de livres les
aventures de lolo chez les blaireaux du
bord de l'eau très chaud pour les petits
marie leurs actions de maryse et le
barman qui ne l'ouvrent qu'à bon escient
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
vient enfin
m
[Musique]
colas
son coup de main
avant on me parlait
europe 1
m
ce soir gagner une seule machine philips
répondait en tapant 36 crime spread à 2
à la question suivante combien
existe-t-il des versions de mammy blue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jacky oui vous avez dû en voir passer
des modèles
et qu'est ce qu'elle vous dise jacky
vous avez dû en voir passer des vedettes
tout
non sauf une eddie barclay et qu'est ce
qu'il dit mais il ne dit pas monsieur
il s'est alors il dit bonsoir bonsoir
quand tu es en forme ça va que va bien
tout va bien tu vois plusieurs en blanc
les vacances la fabrique t dictée dans
le midi tout habillés en blanc quoi oui
ça passe mieux à la machinerie changer
tous les jours
tout va bien tu as quel âge l'a71
maintenant ouais ben hur après ta labour
quand même nom dont tu vas tu vas tout
va sur une femme charmante ses amis
durables des artistes qui m'entourent et
mon activité et débordant dis moi tu as
eu ce cancer quand même ya un peu plus
de dix ans maintenant
ça prouve qu'on ne meurt pas toujours tu
y vas de temps en temps il te regarde on
regarde le contrôle du bon ça va jamais
encore le mais bryant avait encore du
temps tous les combien de berger été
contrôlé à le merdy est contrôlé à peu
près toutes les heures et nuit c'est à
dire tu vois tu vois combien de deux
bergers par jour douzaine d'ailleurs je
vais faire un berger barclay parce que
maintenant
on va lancer ça au mois de septembre
bonjour je bois je dois boire beaucoup
d'eau en plus oui on je bois du berger
avec sans doute beaucoup d'eau par jour
alors une douzaine une douzaine de 1
seulement et ça ne tourne pas la tête je
me bats de change pas les fans km autour
du site en bois pas qu'est ce qui se
passe rien
je bois du bordeaux ouais mais si tu
vois pas de berger pas de bordeaux chez
grave je meurs alors il business ça
marche tu fais des affaires toujours
nagé une dizaine de sociétés qui font
des productions particulière alors
allons-y alors il ya d'abord le les
disques il ya délit ce qui s'appelle
comment les disques barclay libéré il ya
une société qui organise des fêtes jeudi
qui organise les fêtes ça se passe
comment si on veut se faire organiser
une fête par barclays qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire
on téléphone à mon téléphone mon
collaborateur alain marois ni et on
si particulière ses pouvoirs fait pour
lancer un produit pur c'est pas un grand
mariage union de manifestations quelle
qu'elle soit
et puis on organise par rapport à la
personnalité lui organise la fête sur
mesure avec des orchestres nationaux
citizen bezina tard dans les fêtes
tu garantit les stars ne pleut pas il ne
peut jamais garantir leicester mais on
peut en faire venir et ça coûte combien
une fête organisée par barclays entre
500 1000 et
on a ri quand même les mecs te paye
toujours toujours lama qui dit c'était
pas bien
non non non l'a examiné lui est pas
venue de john est arrivé en retard
jamais arrivé ces chaînes privées
tentent et combien de fait part en
tonneaux organise combien une
demi-douzaine a quand même a quand même
et alors et en parfums alors le parfum
on l'a sorti quelques quelques mois
alors tu es appelé le parfum saint
tropez et le maire de saint tropez
monsieur spada lui n'est pas content on
lui dit qu'on n'a pas le droit de
prendre le volant de sa ville pour se
l'attribuer à des fins commerciales
d'abord sais pas j'ai pas de nom de sa
ville c'est le nom de la ville est vrai
de sa ville aujourd'hui les maires de
mètres après fut maire donc ça veut pas
ça veut pas dire que c'est sa ville sa
ville comme c'est la mienne rien donc ne
trompait pas s'attribuer le nom d'une
ville jusqu'aux plus hauts cris
s'attribuer le nom de paris mais ça le
rend par exemple sorti un parfum qui
s'appelle par liszt les juifs dans
l'europe
dommage est sorti sans trappe et dénis
barclays toute cette bande de saint
tropez convoi dans paris match tous les
étés passés la bande si mabanda - plus
loin cela demandeurs avec les gens qui
veulent absolument faire partie de la
bande y sont prêts à quelle bassesse
pour y arriver
quelle bassesse
nous sommes huit royalement il envoie
des avions d'hélicoptères quelques fois
même de son plat donner de l'argent
tout ça pour vous à marcher chez eux oui
vous venir chez nous oui et le pire que
tu as vu dans le genre c'est quoi quid
du jura qui viennent en hélicoptère ils
viennent quelquefois s'imposer comme ça
les sortants sur le terrain les travaux
d'aider des gens qui attendent même
derrière les grilles de l'homme
le lot de la porte d'entrée qui force
presque la porte d'un des gens voilà on
voudrait vous donniez un tableau enfin
toute la nation est incroyable et tu
fais quoi pour t'en débarrasser
je suis je suis pas là alors tu dis que
ce n'est pas la foule pas là
[Musique]
s'expliquant sur la plage avec le chien
pour voir si les filles non parce que
qu'est ce que vous faites ici août en
vacances a sonné juste pour causer une
oeuvre
jacques thomas aw est jésus veut arriver
là ce que vous parlais tout à l'heure
c'est en vacances ouais aux trois
semaines cherche un peu d'écho papa ben
ouais ça vaut ses rêves de faire visiter
la région éventuellement pourquoi mourir
ouais ouais mais sur quoi je connais
vraiment personne aussi la crème vous en
mettre tous dans la creuse pourtant des
traces côté blanc allaient ouais c'est
bon j'ai super c
regardez mon sac je vais aller au petit
coin
merci billets pas demain je fais
confiance à genève connaissez mais
pourquoi il est arrivé comme ça moi je
veux qu en sus l'habitude je sais j'en
viens à la taille de sa poitrine 1 1
voilà vraiment visiter la région elle
avant ce soir
tes copains là je te mettre la crème
mais je peux quand même savoir faire
particulier sera l'apothéose fois tous
les deux mois
tous les trous sur lesquels un la plage
ensemble
ah non non non vous avez choisi vous
[Musique]
d'aller croquer un morceau de quoi
garder mes rondeurs web d une belle
poitrine on voit pas trop de vent pour
rêver pardon voilà on se donne rendez
vous au pont comment dormir
fazeli choses se déroulent bien même
[Musique]
vous êtes connu comment dans un casting
c'est à dire casting à lyon
ouais tout et des castings pour trouver
ses fans restés cois l'or explique nos
noms je cachais pour trouver de
nouvelles angélique remarqué de bizarre
ah bon je suis avec mon ami robert
hossein et ça va se faire 2
trouver la nouvelle du chêne murphy et
trouver cette dame tu la garder pour toi
finalement oui c'est moi mais ça s'est
passé comment au départ je vous dire
comment et à draguer en gros quoi bon ça
je suis allé à ce casting avec des
qu'aucune parce qu'en fait
on va aller pour voir débarquer pour et
puis donc il m'a dit que c'était au
théâtre j'ai dit que mais en fait je
n'ai jamais fait de théâtre que c'est
pas du tout avoir en talons hauts 4 et
donc jeudi par contre j'étais intéressé
par les toucher à la communication les
relations publiques j'envisageais de
faire d'ailleurs des stages à la rentrée
à paris bon pour résumer la chose en
fait pendant six mois je vous monte
régulièrement à paris
à chaque fois pendant six mois j'ai
rappelé
donc toi tu vas pas céder pendant six
mois et un jour tu as aidé c'est
compliqué ce qu'il a fait pour te faire
céder ses machines fois donc au bout
pratiquement de six mois ouais il
m'appelait à lyon tout ce temps là il
est évident patience vraiment une
galanterie tout énervé quoi ils
s'apprêtaient à traiter de quoi de
bernadette soubirous et alors là la
chose s'est fait très rapidement
ben oui on s'est plus vu pendant quelque
temps puis quand même rappeler celle qui
tarde à fait à ce moment là non la parie
ma part à pied elle est arrivée avec ses
valises en avait à coeur comme raccourci
la corse et mais c'est la vérité
la fois devant d'abord ka-sat aquatique
mandaté jeudi qu'il vient passer le
week-end et manon je chope jeu vient
habiter ou pas bah oui hein et là ça
fait cinquante sept maris ça se passe
comment leur chose un petit bilan
est-ce qu'il est fidèle c'est ensemble
qu'ils verraient oui
idéal j'imagine de quoi tu le crois oui
je crois moi dis moi alors maintenant
question importante parce que c'est vrai
que valence
non pas du tout déçu agents voyage enfin
certaines moi dans ma vie ouais non non
franchement mesdames bien remplie n'a
pas dit avant de l'épouser tu sais ça va
être très dur avec moi tu n'auras jamais
l'enfant etc
au contraire de ce qu'il m'a dit il ya
quelques temps sur si j'en avais envie
de thé d'accord aussi pour vous en
faites pas alors pour différentes
raisons d'abord j'ai deux enfants d'une
part d'autre part j'ai 71 genre où je me
demande si vraiment survie d'un enfant
maintenant sur la suite des événements
ça c'est la vie de centenaires soit oui
norma fin à dix mois et et huit femmes
toi quand même non le 8e 1 la plus belle
ouais était en fête à divorcer que six
fois parce que ta première femme est
décédée au bout d'un an et demi de
mariage
et est ce que tu crois que si ça n'était
pas arrivé
est ce que tu crois purée eu comme ça
tout c'est toutes ces femmes
tout est par hasard dans la vie c'est
par hasard
est ce que tu dis je t'aime ah oui oui
ou très galant il sait y faire avec les
femmes c'est mieux aller mais quand
d'expérience
donc j'aime pas les hommes qui sont trop
sûrs d'eux et ça rien à voir avec
l'expérience de jeu c'est pour ça que je
préfère plutôt les les hommes sa
poubelle hauts revenus qui sont moins
sûr
[Rires]
et bien c'est bien commencé prendre
sinon bah oui bien l'expérience dans
tous les domaines tu vas rester avec lui
bazire est sympa comme ça oui
[Musique]
allez les gars de dégâts
tu fais de toi
si tu as la cucaracha
[Musique]
le prendre là
cet impact colis coppola
ok du bozio dimanche
[Musique]
oh
et sont là
là
[Musique]
quel est bas
cette info
ne t'en fait pas des terres
le toit ionisants
[Musique]
j'en ai de joie
koné
tu es
des dégâts
[Musique]
déjà là
hahaha
échos des dégâts
[Musique]
sous le soleil de briller
sous de 20 ou plus est
parce que
georges de rien
[Musique]
les corses de manga
quand tu donnes
la règle
[Musique]
les gars
souci
il sera toujours
[Musique]
vous n'avez jamais essayé d'avoir
l'humour jacky ça n'a pas marché non
vous savez l'humour que c'est comme
l'amour faut faire sans se regarder
faire et moi je m'écoutais c'était bien
quand même ce qui c'est l'histoire d'un
homme qui est en train de jouer le fils
place sa balle de golf il prépare son
club et au moment de taper dans la balle
et il tape tellement fort que la balle
part très très loin alors il court
derrière sa balle de golf il court il
court il court et ne voit plus à bâle
alors il voit un homme qui passe par là
et lui dit pardon monsieur ce que vous
n'auriez pas vu ma balle de golf et
l'autre lui répond qu'elle va vous aime
bien quand même chèque
[Musique]
alors thérèse bonsoir soins alors autant
le dire tout de suite vous avez 85 ans
oui j'ai de cogolin
vous êtes d'une famille clermontaise qui
s'est installée à cogolin en 18 cents à
la vous faites vite et j'ai fait des
pipes thomas w voilà alors expliquez
nous comment on fait des pipes et
d'abord pourquoi les pics de cogolin
sont meilleures que celles d'ailleurs
c'est un rapport à la bruyère
ah bon parce qu'il ya que la bruyère des
morts qui est bonne pour faire les
douces et voilà me revoilà la bruyère et
ça ça se trouve où ce dernier fournit
pas de l'avenir comment la traite quand
on en trouve un morceau comme ça mais
voilà on l'a dans la béroche
elle est pleine de petites pierres c'est
dans la terre on a des gauches
on a coupé comme ça ouais ça c'est les
bouchons les bouchons ne fait bouillir
pendant 14 heures toute une nuit
pourquoi parce que ça pue tous les
petits verts qui peut y avoir dans ma
tête et ensuite on les fait sécher 4,35
comme ça dépend on ne le prenait pas
attendre que cinq ans en or blanc
débauche one a alors commencé à voir le
lui ai dit
on a lancé ça
là elle est presque terminée en tant qu
on passe le personnel pour m le to go et
il en quoi le tuyau un économique et ont
fait toutes sortes de formes
maintenant ça c'est la chasse eh ben ça
c'est là c'est le monsieur
quelqu'un peut barbu quelques photos qui
aiment la fumée ça c'est la sherlock
holmes est votre préférée c'est vraiment
de plus c'est qu'on vous conseillé aux
étudiants saluant plus au début ça c'est
la loi au sénat des jolies robes et et
puis on a quand même bien aimé le show
fota d'être exécuté si ça c'est la poire
ça c'est la peep le gros fumeurs fument
à voitures défilent en travaillant dans
nos jardins
après on l'appli on appelle de la pac
est éliminé dans la poule à après ya ça
le gros spip de bureau comme vous
voudriez quand on a fumé
l'assurance maladie elle ne se pose
c'est la pipe que finaliste à halle en a
et puis après vous avez la peep racines
vous voyez cela on a baissé la route du
bois pour conseiller les fumeurs pendant
six mois je me suis excusé de mâcon
terre rebelle je vais vous nous demandez
de notre beau si vous les aimez droite
cours de langue a pu et puis la qualité
si vous voulez le stress et la peep
flammes et c'est le coeur de la racine
parce que la racine est comme ça au
milieu vous avez le coeur et de du coeur
c'est quand même le coeur le corps
humain et par des veines et alors là bas
toutes les places étaient les bennes et
après comme kanouté ayant aussi la
bruyère qui fait l'homme de perdrix
c'est tout petit peu comme ça c'est la
brière très serré et qui est très bonne
et red bulls haussiers le commissaire le
tout et vous avez toujours fait les
livres je n'ai jamais eu envie de faire
autre chose
parce que j'aime le bois c'est une joie
des matières où se cultive
ah non vous êtes quoi manger police et
au lycée et puis après je vernis c'est
parce qu'il y en a qui demeureront il y
en a qui ne veulent voir même un moment
donné c'est elle à nouveau que les noirs
les sablés et aujourd'hui les modes
c'est quoi un petit année vous avez
commencé à travailler à quel âge c'est
curieux à 12 ans on faisait pas
référence à 12 ans salle et ont ramassé
les copeaux de ses bêtes
voilà la couture on me faisait passer
les paliers de plus peur d'une paire à
l'autre de donner toute votre vie pour
cette usine pour la tamise courrier
d'ailleurs j'ai vu marie dès maintenant
j'ai vu m thierry le fils toute ma
famille je suis de la maison je suis
dans la famille
vous ne voyez plus encore un peu des
poils au mois d'août contient des petits
pots de fleurs je vais poser là encore
jouer que ça va continuer longtemps tout
ça bah ouais si vous saviez depuis qu'on
a fait la campagne anti-tabac condamne
plus de people jamais les grosses
punaise 1 et bien le public nippon et qu
on le croirait pas on a des des plateaux
que pour les pipes de femme de peter
un film comme ça c'est joli et alors
quand vous étiez plus jeune les gens se
moquent êtes-vous en dix ans thérèse
elle fait des pipelines déroulera sans
arrêt salduz état il ne disait pas du
secteur comment il fait des
plaisanteries à la fabrique au magasin
quand j'ai demandé une cachette de la
femme les hommes même fait quelques
petites ne peut pas plus que ça voulait
c'était le client
[Musique]
jacqueline cocktail s'il vous plaît je
vous sers le préféré de ma première
femme monsieur pourquoi vous vous êtes
séparés c'est une histoire banale
monsieur ma femme ressembler à nicoletta
et tous mes amis me disaient c'est fou
ce que ta femme ressemble à nicoletta
j'ai moi je n'étais pas dupe s'il savait
que ça n'était pas nicoletta tout va
bien alors oui mais un matin je les
quitte est monsieur pourquoi le chantait
faux
[Musique]
je suis parti aux soins des séries
s'en passer
sûrement pas
le
si la peau
m
ben c'est faux billets en gt paul thomas
[Musique]
oh
au mas
[Musique]
d'où ma mémoire
o o
jamais
aujourd'hui je te veux y est
je reprends tout ce chemin
qui m'arrête
je
[Musique]
je ferai avec
yep je ne mens pas
oh
mes amis
obama
l'eau
ma mère
[Musique]
maison
le dirais pas
le chalet chiens sont prêts
[Musique]
dire adieu
le genre
dans sa villa
que j'aime
toujours en cours
tout jeu
[Musique]
paris
mam
ça
[Musique]
oh
on y colle et avant ce soir tout cela
alors cette chanson mamy blue c'était en
quelle année 72 72
oui c'est pas s'il ya finalement renoncé
il ya plus de vingt ans ben non moi je
ne suis pas rendu compte qu'il a écrites
sur ces hubert giraud walemme
compositeur que la musique éléments le
soleil et le même moteur pire de l'année
il ya eu 140 version dans nos outils
qu'il a chanté cette chanson
moi je l'entends du même en turc ouais
ouais avoir une structure que ça fait
oui un homme william diana moy
oriane la mort il le fait parce que
j'étais numéro un turc et rabat et j'y
suis allé à la bowie
alors en plus moi c'était un peu une
chanson sur mesure parce que tout le
monde dont ils étaient les gens tout le
monde savait que c'est ta grand-mère qui
t'avait élevé alors quand tu as fait
mammy blue
tout le monde cherche un peu ennuyés
parce que j'avais pas du tout et c'est
bien de l'alluré est en train de le
faire et quand je dire si j'étais un peu
de culture ouhlala ouais je veux pas de
cet ex tama mais elle n'est pas encore
morte et avait peur que ça avec cette
année mais exactement qu'elle ait peur
que d'avoir l'impression que j'enterre
exactement donc j'ai dû préparer ma
grand'mère tu en donnes casey jones et
mamies finalement la chanson que j'ai
dit que je faisais pas toi y'a un petit
problème et c'est rien c'est une chanson
qui sait ce que c'est faux chantier pour
les ou alors elle a très bien pris et
c'est vrai que cette chanson bon c'était
ma plus grosse des lices et j'ai
toujours pensé quelque part qu'il
m'était destinée tueur a demandé combien
de cette chanson j'en suis rien tu sais
pas non moi je connais pas mais vendredi
ça m'intéresse pas j'ai énormément vendu
j'ai déjà du mal à retenir mes impôts je
continue pas je sais que j'ai dû vendre
800 me dit je ne sais pas mais quand
même c'était rapporter beaucoup d'argent
très peu pas j'avais un contrat très
faible c'est une chanson tu ta en pleine
gloire à l'époque mais c'est pas la
période la plus heureuse de ta vie parce
que à l'époque tu te sentais un peu un
peu seul comme ça au milieu du
système du show-business c'était un peu
perdus non j'ai beaucoup donné beaucoup
donné au système beaucoup travaillé et
plus je travaillais plus j'avais la
gorge
je me sentais sale con mais c'est dans
ma porte même de ma chance à douchez
rire de notre côté je dois ma poupée et
ça moi je peux pas le supporter j'ai
besoin de convivialité
j'ai besoin de chaleur humaine j'ai
besoin de partager les choses que je
retrouve avec mes copains avec avec les
miens avec mon conjoint
bon maintenant avec mon enfance et la
chance d'en avoir un et je un jour j'ai
craqué je suis parti dans mon pays au
bord du léman
j'ai trouvé une petite ferme à 10 ans un
peu d'altitude je vais retaper ai dit
que je pouvais tu as fait quoi bon alors
j'ai fait beaucoup d'écoles j'ai très
agitée beaucoup de collèges j'ai même
fait cinq six mois de bon pasteur c'est
en passeur c'était à l'époque ne vous
années 60 qu'il ne maison on mettait des
jeunes filles terrible mais c'est pas
tout à fait la maison de correction
c'était une progression religieuse dont
la maison mère était à angers avec 48
heures en france j'étais parce que c'est
devenu maintenant et ça subissait encore
des lois un petit peu optimiste et enfin
tu vois ce que je veux dire
mais c'est une belle expérience quand on
a eu la chance de vivre dans ce genre de
micro société avec le sao prend le sens
de la hiérarchie on prend le sens du
capot on à propos on apprend surtout
avoir la liberté dans sa tête on peut
être derrière des barreaux être ligne
pour faire du rebelle a définitivement
moi je pense qu'il faut être bête qui
13h c'est très important c'est quand
même très simple comment tu étais arrivé
à la chanson commence à lui la chanson
j'ai commencé très tôt dans l'église de
nos villages quand j'avais 8 et d'années
dans la chance dans mon petit village
savoyard avoue être très belle église du
très belle acoustique et des sommes
fabuleuses et quand j'étais petite fille
je travaille la musique que curry de ce
village parce que j'étais d'une façon
catholique j'étais enfant ma
j'ai la messe tous les matins à l'école
je ferais si les orateurs d'état c'est
ma vie et j'y tiens beaucoup
parce qu'il très belle enfance et ce
prêtre était très bon musicien et je
préparais donc les cantiques pour les
messes de minuit les messes de pâques le
dimanche et dans mon village
tout le monde a l'air et la chorale
étaient des gens du village le
charcutier mes voisins et c'est vrai que
vend très longtemps jusqu'à l'âge de 15
ans au moins
j'ai cru que ça faisait partie quotidien
de la vie des gens la musique et la
chanson je crois que tout le monde
savait chanter et ses talents au collège
je crois que des gens qui chantait faux
comme les patates une belle rencontre
avec la maison en tôle et oui bon ça
c'était avant et ça fait quoi après
alors une fois que la chanson dont il ya
eu je fais donc je me ses succès mais
justement qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après après quoi la fin un enfant tu as
vu dans occupé djamel marié et en 77
gens des procédures et alexandre en mai
j'ai voulu vraiment vu ma grossesse ou
des véhicules ou vraiment vous êtes mon
fils me dit maman à moi et puis voir ses
premiers pas en tant de ses premiers
rires parce que ça je voulais pas qu'on
me vole je concède très important quand
on décide des maires il faut de vie bien
sûr c'est un choix primordial le
problème c'est qu'après quand tu as
voulu revenir dans le métier il aperçu
que c'était difficile parce que j'étais
parti tu vois là tu as laissé tu as tout
laisser tomber puis quand est revenue
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors d'abord
pourquoi tu es revenu pourquoi t'es pas
réussi à gérer parce que j'ai besoin de
travailler pour gagner ma vie je me suis
séparée du père de mon fils me séparer
d'un commun accord ça arrive
oui donc sur parti prendre le micro
gibbons et recommence à zéro on prend le
bébé on à paris non ces brouilles et mon
producteur à l'époque vendait sa
compagnie dit
papy nous parce que je vous dis monsieur
berdos avait 110 je connais un petit peu
sur les voies de garage parce qu'elle
est et non d'une grosse multinationale
et comme beaucoup de nougaro richardson
comment on se trouvait quelques artistes
à se débrouiller recommence à zéro donc
jetterait partie de ces mots dits
indépendants
tu l'as vécu comment ce changement de
situation c'est à dire ce passage
finalement toutes les statues temps les
télés les machins les trucs et d'un seul
coup on vas tu reviens après l'enfant à
paris comment tu l'as vécu ça c'était
une fille solide bien sûr enfin ça a été
dur quand même
ce qui est dur c'est que souvent les
gens moi ce qui me le plus pénible c'est
parce que j'en parle à l'imparfait
oui moi je suis fan du futur moi
j'essaie d'avancer de philosophie de vie
le moment présent et surtout de me
donner des visions de visualiser mon
futur sur un an seulement et d'avoir et
de prendre le temps de faire ce que j'ai
à faire c'est pas seulement chanter
souci vous occuper des gens que j'aime
et pouvoir me consacrer parce quand je
travaille beaucoup les gens que j'aime
et vous voyez jamais donc je vais me
faisait souffrir
alors faut déjà l'enfant alors attendre
qu'ils nous voient ma grand mère elle
n'est pas mort un train parce que tu
joues elle est prête à g est là avec moi
et avec toi tu la prise avec assez
normal chez nous laissa brière les
montagnards ont gardé lieu à la maison
tu as dit j'avais pas les dents assez
longue
ça veut dire que tu étais pas prêtes à
tout donner pour être une énorme star
que tu aurais pu être une énorme énorme
tas avec la voie que tu avais et
pourquoi alors tu te mets pas tout
sacrifier quoi ces sachets de riz cuit
parce que la gloire quand on est en haut
de la pyramide tu sais y'a pas beaucoup
de place pour tout le monde parce que
j'avais des rêves doit faire froid leur
parler tout seul tout seul
j'ai connu un petit peu ça m'a fait peur
[Musique]
bonjour voila on débarque sur la côte on
vient d'arriver
on n'a rien à se mettre alors vous allez
m'habiller évidemment la badr ont donc
on paye pas alors voilà comme on l'est
antilles a glance semble ou alors il
faut qu'on s'habille pour l'été je
t'écoute maintenant tu m'avais dit mme
lemesle et linate au mollet mais c'est
un mot qui dit mais on a dit de la tête
aux pieds de la montre on la doit aussi
vous allez me filer une aquarelle
j'ai pas la porte mais moi je m'en fous
du prix de façon je paye rien moi vous
me rouler parce qu'il n'a pas marqué non
plus aux manutentionnaires
qu est ce qu on dit merci mais il faut
gueuler un bon jour je vous explique que
vous avez noir 1 c'est vous allez nous
payer des glaces à toute l'équipe vous
avez moins de 30 secondes alors money
ball qu on n'a pas la journée est ce qu
on dit merci monsieur
allez salut bonne bourre allez on rentre
vous me ferez une montre regardez ça
s'appelle un voyageur donc il me faut un
froch léger et puis autre chose que des
tags de contente
ils m'ont dit merci les deux oui c'est
donc là ce que je peux lui cela non plus
envelopper les on n'a pas la journée
[Musique]
subsonic paniqué a dans ce cas là il
faut demander tu veux nique et madame
gay chemisier soit 900 bas ok ça me va
bien
la blouse un peu ta des rebonds des
bonnes seul homme
bon ce que j'espère c'est que on va
aller chez toi et on va tirer
ok allez on y va didon s'est dit mal les
capotes tribal a pas d'image 2020
grand bal a soutenu que j'ai pu
finalement c'est les capotes dix balles
quand même
monique enfin décoller qu'est ce que
c'est le truc le plus cher lancera deux
pays
ce sont les côtés de monsieur et faut
compter combien pour 66 alors faites pas
chier mais moi je dérange c'est vous le
patron oui
donc tu oses explique on arrive à saint
tropez on n'a pas de rond dont vous
allez nous rase a convié à 19 ans à 66 x
au nom vous nous mettez carrie fisher
ben c'est pas parce qu'on paye pas
qu'ils commencent à dire de la merde
une bouteille et combien cela 440 30
c'est pas le meilleur
ses sponsors officiels de la maison on
s'en bat les couilles serre bonjour on
fait un reportage sur les vieux croûtons
bourré de blé il est où
we're in the boss parce qu'il nous a
invités avec l'équipe pour huit jours on
va dormir ici et nous je sais mais il
nous a invités donc doit-on chocs et à
la compta 1 donc tu vas tu vas et on va
résister lorsque la machine molle tout
ça du blaireau ce qu'on va faire on est
toute une équipe nous on va s'installer
huit jours ici d'accord alors pour le
menu t'inquiète pas on mange de tout
simplement tu fous pas le bordel parce
qu'on donne jusqu'à midi d'accord bon là
il ya un yo qui sont des rippeurs sympa
mon avis je vais passer
on se voit je vous appellerai au camping
et mike moi je suis avec mes potes sont
pas tous cas
un jeu
danse
moi j'aurais amis j'ai juste envie
ce à l'autriche regarde moi je crache
tout on va courir on croirait en plus
j'ai même pas la couleur
j'ai perdu mes lunettes il faut qu'on
aille dans une boutique chercher des
lunettes on va marcher comme si de rien
n'était on va essayer de ne pas se faire
remarquer allez y
[Musique]
elle a troqué son bac ramer contre une
kippa et tout l'allusion religieuse est
absolument déposants de sa volonté
c'est à l'arraché welch et ça se bosse
enfin j'adore il serait pas une terre
plus 3
pour
[Musique]
tours
chaud
[Musique]
m
tous
[Musique]
il
comment
toute l'eau
[Musique]
m
j'ai du mal à imaginer un petit jacky en
culottes courtes déjà barman très bien
dû faire autre chose avant jacky entre
l'être et le paraître
je n'ai pas choisi monsieur soyez créa
par une fois jacky c'était en 42 à vichy
au bar de l'hôtel du parc
même si mise au piano motus que gardel
monsieur même qu'elle ait commencé prête
à jouer
soudain une voix s'est élevée des tonga
qui quand vous aurez terminé une servira
un cognac qui résistaient monsieur
[Musique]
d'après
à ce jour 20 des traits
salut andré après-demain plus après midi
à quesques en galère l'as coteaux va
lire on va dire beaucoup de billets à
temps on va dire des très différents
d'abord un livre en livre de poche qui
est extraordinaire qui l'élève de
vincent van gogh à théo eu alors vincent
gandois vous l'avez vu d'abord sous les
traits de kirk douglas et puis
souhaiterait le shaq dutronc oui et puis
maintenant il faut le lire parce que ça
c'est encore plus intéressant et c'est
fabuleux de voir ce type
quitus et n'a jamais vendu 1 une toile
de sa vie qu'il était dans un état pas
possible et qui en fait a demandé à
s'offrir d'être son imprésario et ce
type qui était dans un état de misère
dans un état de fait qui nous demander
quelque chose je veux pas il faut des
mois la paix alors on l'embêté tu sais
il va à arles il s'installe arles et
puis va voir les plus crues et il ya une
pétition qui circule dans dix ans une
espèce de hollande est fou qui veut voir
les [ __ ] qui est qui mal rasé qui était
espèce de beatniks avant la lettre ait
eu des pétitions pour l'éloigner et
comme tu sais il a été offert sur oise
et c'est là bas qu'il est mort or ce
livre retrace dix huit ans de lettres de
vincent van gogh à 131 et c'est la plus
belle confession je crois qu'ils aient
jamais été écrit par un artiste parce
qu'ils montrent que à teplice est
vraiment brûlé qui s'est brûlé en se
disant mais attendez laissez moi perdre
tout ce qu'ils demandaient mais
laissez-moi respirer tu vois et il faut
lire en même temps next orient textes
d'antonin artaud qui s'appelle van gogh
le suicidé parce que ce sont pas des
livres difficile et ce sont des livres
qui flambent
tu sais en général on te parle toujours
un peu de guimauve de choses qui se
passent
et bien la laisser voilà la passion à la
passion d'un mec dont les mots
deviennent des couleurs dont les mots
deviennent vraiment des espèces de masse
sol et sur la toile donc vincent van
gogh toujours en premier livre les
lettres de van gogh
après après alors une italienne
italienne fantastique l'italienne qui a
des couilles
mais bien qu'elle ait connu beaucoup
plus beaucoup de mecs cap l orient n'a
pas la jada sur la fal hachey une très
grande journaliste très grande
romancière écrit un bouquin
inch allah qui se passa les routes avec
tu sais la force d'interposition
italienne elle raconte je veux pas
raconter tout se prendre les heures
comment il ya eu la force
d'interposition française qui salue le
quartier général français les cartes et
gère l'américain en déroute qui ont
sauté par les mollahs par les fils
il raconte parce qu'elle est allée faire
des reportages là bas il faut lire ce
livre parce que c'est un extraordinaire
compte rendu de ce qu'a été beyrouth le
liban dans cette guerre civile est elle
le raconte en romancière ça veut dire
encore mieux qu'un journaliste pourquoi
parce qu'elle va à l'intérieur des gens
à la hauteur des consciences amateurs
des personnages et les histoires d'amour
des histoires de tendresse mais on
comprend beaucoup mieux le liban que si
on lisait 40 journaux et en fait on
comprend la bosnie herzégovine mais
comprendre tout ce qui est aujourd'hui
nous menacent si on laisse faire si tu
veux les nationalismes les ethnies les
ngn de classe les identités comme si
chacun d'entre nous n'était pas d'abord
une manip et à moins d'être une
étiquette une identité ou autre et il
faut dire que rien n'a pas l'habitude cc
l'intervieweuse ses gammes la vie qui
est allé voir l'ayatollah khomeiny à
téhéran
on lui a dit tu béton tchador parce que
sans ça tu ne te reçois pas or elle est
de van commenee et combine la regarde
pas comme unis est assis sur son tapis
il a les yeux par terre on dit rien elle
lui dit mais regardez moi dans les yeux
pour me regarde pas dans les yeux
pourquoi vous ne regardez pas et alors
il dit mais vous êtes une femme je vous
regarde pas vous êtes une femme je
regarde pas et alors elle le dit
regardez moi lève les yeux et elle
enlève son tchador
elle me jette et 10 à ses larmes de l'
esclavage des femmes c'est l'art de la
suggestion sait que faire ça chez
commenee atterrant faut le faire c'est
ça on n'y en a pas lâcher et elle est
allée kissinger puis s'est rappelé tous
deux qu'ils gèrent le petit professeur
d'origine allemande qui dirigeait vers
la politique américaine sous nixon et ce
gerald ford et elle va le voir et lui
dit mais dites moi c'est quoi est
politique et lui dit moi je vais vous
dire moi je voudrais euros rentrant seul
sur son cheval et délivrant la ville el
hadji dia bon et il dit visite - à vous
plaisait aux femmes a dit oui mais dit
mais vous êtes les c'est vrai que
kissinger s'est épanoui vous savez le
pouvoir c'est aphrodisiaque et elle a
publié sa maman playboy l'église digère
lui a fait une histoire pas possible
voilà falacci une leçon de courage
une leçon de talent et merveilleux roman
inch'allah et enfin un tout petit livre
très très très beau coup vous lire sur
la page qui est un livre d'amour et on
aime bien les livres d'amour ça
s'appelle une passion d'annie ernaux là
je vole au secours de la victoire qui
marche vraiment la veille de toutes les
ventes depuis des mois magnifiques mais
c'est un livre merveilleux qui me touche
et qu'est ce que c'est très très simple
est amoureuse d'un mec le mec est marié
le mec va l'avoir disons tout simplement
pour la sauter et il repart et cette
fille est entrée en passion elle est
entrain passion elle choisit des parfums
qu'il aime la robe qu il m
elle attend qu'ils viennent elle attend
un coup de téléphone la passion ça
existe depuis des siècles las eto'o fax
avant c'était avec madame bovary c'était
avec les lettres et tu as de la manière
la plus simple la plus sobre la plus
dépouillée un récit d'une passion
féminine pour un mec qui à jour
disparaîtra qui retrouvera sa famille en
yougoslavie ou ailleurs et qu'elle
n'enverra jamais et cette espèce de
chant d'amour d'une sobriété absolument
totale teulet ce que tu sois hommes
femmes au complètement
je veux dire à la thérapie te dis je
voudrais une passion comme ça je
voudrais connaître une personne
voilà donc tu as la passion la passion
artistique la flamme
tu as là flammes de l'enfer politique et
puis enfin la flamme de refaire moon
alors vous êtes sur les plages rouler
sous le soleil brûle et avec ses boucles
bravo andrée
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci d'avoir passé cette soirée
avec nous au bar de la plage prochaine
ouverture samedi prochain salut bande de
la rage
[Musique]
chaque jeu
je n'ai pas que j'avais
comment chacun
je n'ai
je n'ai pas
non
m
[Musique]
j'accompagne jeu
ses compagnons d'échappée
dans mon coeur
[Musique]
je
non
[Musique]
le grand jeu philips bar de la plage la
question était combien existe-t-il deux
versions de mammy blue
et la réponse 140 version
vous avez gagné un cerne machine philips
comportant un lecteur cd une double
platine k7 et un tuner bravo
antenne 2 et philips vous ont présenté
le bar de la plage
l'émission d'été de tir 10 ans et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux